ein auto ist hier in berlin in eine
menschenmenge gerast der mensch ist
gestorben und das sind die ersten bilder
vom unfallort dort am kudamm mitten im
herzen von berlin schlimme erinnerungen
werden geweckt an dem dezember dort in
der nähe in der gedächtniskirche mitten
in berlin das passiert die ersten bilder
sie sehen hier den kleinwagen ein mensch
wurde getötet zahlreiche menschen wurden
verletzt diese szenen spielen sich jetzt
gerade hier in der hauptstadt ab der
kleinwagen dort offenbar in ein
schaufenster gerast der fahrer dieses
wagens konnte von der polizei
mittlerweile festgenommen werden denn
auch jetzt in diesen minuten ein
großaufgebot dort von polizei und
feuerwehr ein mensch tot zahlreiche
menschen sind verletzt unsere reporter
natürlich auf dem weg dorthin sie sehen
dort stühle und tische wurden
mitgerissen dort ein angrenzendes
straßencafé dort mitten auf dem kudamm
ein toter mehrere verletzte unsere
reporter auf dem weg dorthin der
hintergrund dafür ist bisher noch völlig
unklar die ermittlungen laufen und
derzeit ein großaufgebot von polizei
feuerwehr hier mitten in der hauptstadt
ja man kann im moment noch nicht ganz
genau sagen zuerst hatte die feuerwehr
gemeldet dass 30 verletzte gemeldet
wurden danach wurde die zahl unter
korrigiert auf 10 dementsprechend auf
jeden fall mehrere menschen die dort
eben von diesem auto getroffen wurden
von diesem auto eben verletzt wurden ein
toter betriebsrates gerade gesagt und
unser reporter axel er hat eben gemeldet
der eben schon vor ort ist dass der
fahrer dieses wagens bereits von der
polizei festgehalten wird die weiteren
ermittlungen dazu laufen und auch
weitere reporter von uns sind natürlich
auf den weg dorthin und wir sprechen
gleich mit ihnen sobald sie denn vor ort
sind bisher ist es noch völlig unklar ob
es sich um einen unfall handelt oder ob
der fahrer vorsätzlich in die
menschenmenge gerast und das sind die
bilder die die schrecklichen
erinnerungen wecken sie erinnern sich
dezember 2016 das sind aber jetzt ganz
aktuelle bilder hier vom kudamm mitten
in berlin sie sehen die gedächtniskirche
wenige meter nur entfernt im jahr 2016
terrorist andreas dort in den
weihnachtsmarkt werden uns alle daran
ganz deutschland erinnert sich daran und
jetzt heute an diesem tag nur wenige
meter entfernt rast ein auto in eine
menschenmenge wunderschönes wetter heute
hier in berlin zahlreiche menschen auf
den straßen hier sehen sie das auto das
dort in ein schaufenster gekracht ist
und sie sehen neben dran ein
straßenverkehr café verzeihung dort
viele tische und stühle draußen am
kudamm hier in berlin im herzen berlins
an diesem sonnigen tag garantiert viel
los derzeit geht man von acht verletzten
aus ein mensch ist ums leben gekommen
ein großaufgebot von polizei und
feuerwehr
sie sehen hier die bilder vor der
gedächtniskirche sind derzeit vor ort
auch unsere reporter natürlich jetzt auf
dem weg dorthin um alle hintergründe
herauszufinden ein toter mehrere
menschen verletzt im herzen von berlin
ein auto dort mitten auf dem kudamm in
eine menschenmenge gerast alle details
alle informationen sobald es etwas neues
gibt erfahren sie hier unsere reporter
auf dem weg dorthin und das noch einmal
für sie das erste foto dort vom
unfallort bisher weiß man noch nicht
vorsätzlich oder war es ein unfall die
ermittlungen laufen derzeit großaufgebot
dort aber sie sehen der kudamm eine
belebte die belebte prachtmeile hier in
berlin in der city mitten im herzen und
nur wenige meter entfernt bereits ziel
gewesen eines anschlags am
weihnachtsmarkt 2016 erhalten sie hier
auf dem laufenden sobald es neue
entwicklungen gibt erfahren sie das hier
natürlich breaking news machen wir dann
sofort